مدينه مليتوبول تشكل الان مفتاح الجنوب
للجيش الاكراني فخطت الدفاع الروسي قد
ينهار بعد القصف الذي طال المدينه
الاستراتيجيه التي تسيطر عليها موسكو منذ
فبراير الماضي هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه
ينظر اليها على انها الهدف الرئيسي التالي
للقوات الاوكرانيه وفي جنوب البلاد منذ ان
السعاده اكياس مدينه خيرسون الرئيسيه وفقا
لصحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه القوات
الاوكرانيه تعمل الان على الضفه الشرقيه
لنهر نيبرو مقابل حيث اصبحت قادره على وضع
عنظمات على الضفه الغربيه التي لعبت دورا
محوريه في هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد في جنوب
والشرق الاوكراني موضع طبعا القوات
الروسيه في المدينه تحت تهديد
وفقه الجارديان وفي حال سقطت مليتو بول
فان خط الدفاع الروسي باكمله سين على طول
الطريق الى خرسان طبعا وقد تكتسب القوات
الاوكرانيه طريقه مباشره الى شبه جزيره
القرم كما نتابع هنا هذا الامر طبعا قد
يسهم بان تربح اكياف الحرب ولكن الكلفه
ستكون باهظه جدا على الغرب لان اكياس تطلب
خمسه مليارات دولار شهريا تقول صحيفه وصف
جورد لانه في حال اصبحت الحرب نزاعا مجمدا
مع استمرار القتال في بعض المناطق هذا
يعني ان الاقتصاد الاوكراني لن يتعافى
وسيؤدي الى مزيد من الازمات الانسانيه
ويتطلب طبعا دعاما ماليا دوليا
[موسيقى]